a reporter fact-checked Donald Trump to
his face yesterday and Trump hilariously
seemed to sort of point at her or
someone else and then walk away let's
set it up
Trump lies all the time if you watch
this program regularly you probably know
that and one lie that Donald Trump has
been repeating time and time again is
that his administration's policy of
separating kids at the border from their
families migrant children from their
families is the exact same policy that
the Obama administration had Trump says
we're not doing anything differently
than Trump's than Obama's administration
was doing now in reality where I prefer
to live there's a major difference which
is that Donald Trump is prosecuting
people who show up with the border
including those seeking asylum as part
of a policy that's completely different
than what Barack Obama was doing so
Trump drops this lie in front of some
reporters and then CBS reporter Paula
Reid tells him that he's lying he seems
to either point at her or someone else
and then just walks away not addressing
the fact that he has been fact checked
in real time by a reporter not a fake
news person not an anti-american person
not someone who is being partisan
someone who simply says that is not the
truth these are not the facts and Trump
just walks away take a look Paula Reid
spoke with the president about this at
the White House President Trump
responded to the 60 minutes report by
repeating his claim that President Obama
also separated families so I'll tell you
what Obama had a separation policy we
all had the same policy differently but
Obama had a separation policy but people
don't like to talk so this is what the
media needs to do let's think about this
in a few layers this is what needs to be
done as I've been saying to sarah
huckabee Sanders Trump's deranged and
depraved secretary at every opportunity
real-time fact check
not allowing them to get away with these
lies the next question is whether this
type of fact-checking
convinces any trumpets that Trump is
lying I think the answer is of course
not because one of the most effective
attacks on American media in history has
been carried out by Donald Trump he's
used this guise of fake news as the
problem which has primed the pump for
his followers to distrust anything
that's remotely critical of Trump or
that Trump doesn't like but I still
think it doesn't matter Pat even if the
committed devoted trumpet is not going
to have their mind changed by trumping
fact-checked in real time the press
should be doing their job regardless of
what trump's followers think and that
being said part of why it's easy to do
that is that most reporters don't do
this
so if every reporter did this at every
press event it's going to become much
more difficult for Trump to keep up the
fake news narrative they'll try Pat but
if we actually had a sort of agreement
among the presidential press corps the
people that sit in the press briefing
room the people that asked from
questions it is gonna at least challenge
the Trump is to say wait a second why is
he being directly contradicted about all
of these things that he says maybe some
of them aren't actually true I do like
that but there is an optics issue I
think because of the power imbalance in
that press room like all the reporters
are talking to Trump and they're saying
mr. president might I be able to ask a
question or mr. president that's not
appropriate they're asking or they're
acting with this level of decorum and
then Trump doesn't respond in kind he'll
call them fake news he'll call them out
he'll call them liars and I think a lot
of Trump supporters see that and are
just gonna side with the president and
back him up at any at any case yeah I
mean the committed Trump estat this
point is effectively a brainwashed cult
follower I mean it's like what we don't
need to sugarcoat it anymore that's what
we're dealing with you were dealing with
a dynamic in reaction to Trump as that
is how brainwashed devoted cult
followers behave but I still think that
there are people who can be
there are people who are going to be
embarrassed to vote for the guy that is
called out for lying every press event
and looks like an absolute fool and we
really shouldn't even be arguing about
what the effect will be because this
should just be the standard it's only
happening sometimes but this is how
every member of that press corps should
be dealing with Donald Trump and
remember that this there was that
incident with trump's ambassador to the
Netherlands pete hoekstra he lied and
fabricated out of thin air that
politicians are being burned in the
Netherlands and that there are police
no-go zones what else was it how is it
that there were police no-go zones in
the Netherlands totally untrue of course
and he was called out about it by the
Dutch press and it was a shining example
of how these people need to be dealt
with that's what you've got to realize
when they get called out on the lies
they can't defend them they can get mad
they can walk away they can clam up like
they've lost the ability to speak all of
a sudden but every single reporter
should be doing this because otherwise
they can target the reporters that do it
if it's just Jim Acosta or whoever they
can target them and make it seem like
the problem isn't the press it's just
that reporter if everybody says we are
not going to allow him to get away with
lies we are not going to allow him not
to answer questions in a real way then
it might become much more difficult to
for them to activate against those
reporters without it being clearly an
attack on the freedom of the press which
is exactly what it is and another way to
attack the press is to say we are going
to take over the press with state-run
media and that's what I want to talk
about next Pat I have been waiting for
this day for a long time no it's not the
day that Pat finally announces he's no
longer vegan no it's not the day that my
chess rating finally climbs over 450
it's the day that CNN has started to do
live fact-checking of Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is press briefings as they are
happening with graphics what a day for
nearly two years now I've been saying
the press corps must
check the press briefings the press
corps must insist that questions be
answered if a question is asked and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders doesn't answer it
the next reporter should ask the exact
same question until we get an answer and
I've also been saying if they're not
willing to do that
maybe the network's should just stop
airing the press briefings altogether
and we're gonna have an example of that
later today as well so let's go to
yesterday's press briefing Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the vile depraved
disgusting lying press secretary gives
her first press briefing in nearly a
month
CNN comes out of nowhere with graphics
that pop up on the screen as soon as
Sarah Huckabee sander starts lying and
directly contradict or expose the fact
that she is telling lies so we're gonna
play one clip here in a moment and
you're gonna notice if you're watching
that as Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
talking about this climate change report
from Trump's own administration which
Trump said he doesn't believe they
immediately when she starts lying put up
the graphics that tell you the truth
just the facts not editorialized and if
you're if you're not watching I'll
describe the graphics after if you are
watching you'll actually see these on
screen let's take a look the president
certainly Leaney
leading on what matters most in this
process and that's on having clean air
clean water in fact the United States
continues to be a leader on that front
even Obama's undersecretary for science
didn't believe the radical conclusions
of the report that was released and you
have to look at the fact that this
report is based on the most extreme
model scenario which contradicts
long-established trends modeling the
climate is an extremely go hated science
that is never exact the biggest thing
that we can do is focus on how to make
sure we have the cleanest air the
cleanest water and the president is
certainly doing that and certainly
leaning on that fire you do
the president's about to go to 1 Osiris
and meet with all the leaders of the
world's industrialized nations and
development nations as well isn't this a
great opportunity for him to sit at the
table and say folks this is what my
administration just reported this is the
time that we ought to act in concert to
prevent what my administration is
forecasting off once again we think that
this is the most extreme version and
it's not based on facts it's based on
it's not data-driven we'd like to see
something that is more data-driven it's
based on modeling which is extremely
hard to do yeah not data-driven total
joke so let's now put up the graphics
that popped up on screen when Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and and this the the
freeze-frame we have is just just
priceless when she started lying
CNN simply presented some facts like for
example this climate change report
involved 300 scientists and 13 federal
agencies so Donald Trump and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders are saying that the 300
scientists and 13 federal agencies that
did this are wrong they also point out
that the co-author was not paid for the
report that's another lie that started
being floated and they also pointed out
even though Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
saying that this was extreme and this
was not the the the the most accurate
assessment of the data that's out there
that indeed the report was open for
review and transparency before
publishing in fact it was peer-reviewed
this is what we need okay now I know
lots of Trumpets will say the
fact-checking is fake news it's biased
media screw them they're gonna say that
either way they've been saying it for
two years without CNN simply putting up
uncontroversial facts on the screen so
do it
that's what CNN did now meanwhile MSNBC
took a different approach they simply
ignored the entire press briefing which
I also think is fantastic they didn't
air Larry Kudlow came out first and
talked about how great the economy is
despite GM and Ford laying off 15
percent of their employees as I told you
yesterday MSNBC didn't air it john
bolton came out and said he didn't
listen to the audio tape of jamal
khashoggi being killed because he
doesn't speak Arabic or some other
nonsense MSNBC didn't air that
instead MSNBC reported actual news
instead of propaganda lies from the
administration MSNBC when Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was lying and Bolton was lying
and and that they were all out there
lying they did a story about General
Motors they did a story about trade they
did a story about US workers they
reported on this Guardian report about
Paul Manafort which we're going to talk
about later on in the show they talked
about the Senate election and
Mississippi were unfortunately a racist
Republican was reelected
and then if something actually
newsworthy happens during the briefing
they can report on it they can even
report on it minutes later after it
happens but they don't have to present
this endless propaganda platform to
their audience I think that this is
fantastic Pat the media should have
adopted either of these approaches a
long time ago fact-checking
or not airing it and then reporting on
what's new newsworthy later this is a
level of dystopian dissonance that we
are experiencing here and news outlets
can easily put a three or four minute
delay on these and so that they have
three or four minutes to fact-check
what's being said this is fantastic and
I congratulate them well it sounds to me
like you like the CNN strategy the most
so much so I'm actually worried about
you starting to do this to me like when
I start rambling and going off-the-cuff
going off script you may say like will
David Pakman show facts first come up
over here as a graphic with like a list
of points debunking what I say yeah I
think that that would be a good idea
because that way when people write in
and they say David you know Pat said
something that was absolutely and
completely atrocious you really should
have immediately fact-checked him and
sometimes it's like well listen I don't
want to derail the show I don't want to
insult Pat if we just had a running
commentary of Corrections of Pat on the
side of the screen I think that that's a
really good idea we might just have to
hire someone to do that well I think we
are hiring now right so that could just
be the full-time position so listen yes
if Fox News were to do this their own
fact checks would be ridiculous
but they're already lying anyway and
these other outlets may actually reach
people by doing it so
is good I hope that the media is
actually now starting to grow a backbone
and that they're going to do this
regularly if you think this is a bad
idea okay I want to hear from you why
don't you like this follow me on
instagram at david pakman follow the
show at david pakman show we're gonna
spend some time today looking at a new
interview that donald trump gave to the
washington post every time that trump
gives these long-form interviews to
print media outlets it is a veritable
house of horrors is what I would call it
if it seems that Trump is clueless when
he's talking in these sound bites or
when yelling over the were of his
helicopter on the White House lawn that
is nothing compared to what happens when
Trump actually sits down for a longer
interview with print media who then
published transcripts of what Donald
Trump says and Donald Trump gave one of
these interviews to The Washington Post
he sat down with Josh dossie and Philip
Rucker from the Washington Post and what
I want to do today is really dig into
just a few of the sections there's
really a lot to look at here to get a
sense of it the the way in which it's so
much more evident that the guy has no
clue when you let him talk a little more
when you have a format that allows for
follow-up questions or clarifications
and what we very quickly learn is giving
Donald Trump the opportunity to clarify
actually muddies the water even more it
becomes less clear what he's trying to
say and what he knows so let's just jump
into it and we can talk about some of
these here's a first section ok we're
putting these up on the screen and I'll
read them to you and we'll discuss Josh
dossie ask Trump this was about that
climate change report that Trump says he
just doesn't believe which is his own
administration's report
dossie says you said yesterday when you
were leaving that you were skeptical of
a climate change report that the
government had done can you just explain
why you're skeptical of that report
Trump says one of the problems that a
lot of people like myself we have very
high levels of intelligence but were not
necessarily such believers it's already
in
okay there is no argument to be made
when the president is being asked about
policy that he's very intelligent and
this has been a hallmark of Trump since
he was just candidate Trump talking
about Wharton and who knows what else
Trump goes on to say you look at our air
and our water and it's right now at a
record clean that's nonsense gibberish
and it's also not true and then Trump
goes on to say but when you look at
China and you look at parts of Asia and
when you look at South America and when
you look at many other places in this
world including Russia including just
many other places the air is incredibly
dirty okay I mean I guess he's pointing
out that there's pollution all over the
planet but again it has nothing to do
with the believability of his
administration study and he goes on and
says and when you're talking about an
atmosphere oceans are very small and it
blows over and it sails over what on
earth does that mean I I don't I don't
know what he's talking about
and then he goes on to say I mean we
take thousands of tons of garbage off
our beaches all the time that it comes
over from Asia it flows right down the
Pacific it flows and we say where does
this come from and it takes many people
to start off with the hell is this guy
talking about okay I mean he's pointing
out that the currents and the Pacific
Ocean bring some trash over from Asia to
the west coast of the US that's all true
but Pat does this have anything to do
with the study does this have anything
to do with the question Trump was asked
which was why don't you believe your own
Administration study saying that there's
currents in the ocean that doesn't mean
anything yet all rambling but by the
time you get to the end of it you almost
forget what the question was and maybe
that's why it's so effective for him
yeah and that's why it's often really
good to actually have a sit-down print
interview with Trump because then he
continues on this issue okay let's put
up the next part of his answer which
makes just as little sense Trump says
number two if you go back and if you
look at articles they talked about
global freezing they talked about at
some point the planet could have freeze
to death
and then it's going to die of heat
exhaustion what the hell is he talking
about
right there is movement in the
atmosphere there's no question as to
whether or not it's man-made and whether
or not the effects that you're talking
about are there I don't see it
not nearly like it is he doesn't see
it's nearly like it is isn't he's saying
he doesn't see it the way it actually is
I don't see it not nearly like it is he
goes on to say do we want clean water
absolutely do we want clean air to
breathe absolutely the fire in
California where I was if you looked at
the floor the floor of the fire they
have trees that were fallen they did no
forest management no forints maintenance
and you can light you can take a match
like this and light a trunk when that
thing is laying there for more than 14
or 15 months and it's a massive problem
in California so that that is also
gibberish but it actually refers to a
particular debunked notion that the
fires in California are because of poor
forest management it's wrong I mean it's
just it what he said there is wrong on
the facts on everything and then again
Trump continuing with the lies talking
about climate change saying quote Josh
you go to other places where they have
denser trees it's more dense where the
trees are more flammable they don't have
forest fires like this because they
maintain and it was very interesting I
was watching the firemen and they're
raking brush you know the tumbleweed and
brush and all this stuff that's growing
underneath it's on fire and they're
raking it working so hard and they're
raking all this stuff if that was raked
in the beginning there'd be nothing to
catch on fire it's very interesting to
see a lot of the trees they look
tremendous
they took tremendous burn at the bottom
but they didn't catch on fire the bottom
is all burned but they didn't catch on
fire because they sucked the water they
were wet you need forest management and
they don't have it so again this is if
if you are just wondering is he coming
up with this stuff all on his own he's
not this is something he got from a
misunderstanding of what Finland does
and even Finland has now said what Trump
is saying we're doing is not actually
what we're doing like it it's just all
lies Pat and I feel as the
when you look at the transcript it's
more obvious that he's clueless than
when he yells over his helicopter but I
still think many people aren't getting
the the utter ignorance of what he's
saying here it's especially strange
because he used all of these talking
points last week and they were
thoroughly debunked by a number of news
outlets so a week later to rehash them
as if they hadn't been debunked that
just shows that he's not keeping up to
date on all of the the news stories out
there and he's doing basically the same
thing with the Jamaal khashoggi killing
where if you've been watching our show
you know that on the Jamaal khashoggi
killing Trump's priority has been not
freedom of the press and protecting a
Free Press not human rights not holding
people accountable but his priority has
been to defend Saudi Arabia over saying
he believes them over our own
intelligence agencies check out this
part of the transcript dossie says mr.
president your national security team is
going to the hill tomorrow to brief
senators on Saudi Arabia and Jamal
khashoggi I've heard from Senator Graham
who I know you were with yesterday and
others that they want stronger
punishment on Saudi Arabia tougher
sanctions do you want them to impose
that or do you think that would be
deleterious to our and Trump interrupts
and says I'm gonna listen to what they
say they're all friends of mine and I
get along with them great this is this
is Trump okay who's friends with him
Trump wants to be liked he wants to be
friends with people rather than just
doing the right thing and he goes on and
he says I'm going to certainly listen to
what they have to say Josh in the end
though they're spending massive amounts
of billions of dollars if you look at
Iran and what they do this is a key
point and you look at many other
countries I don't have to embarrass
other countries by saying it if you look
at what they do
it's a rough part of the world it's a
dangerous rough part of the world but
they've been a great ally without them
Israel would be in a lot more trouble we
need to have a counterbalance on Iran I
know him I know him well the crown
prince and by the way never did business
with them never intend to do business
with them that's a lie of course and
then he goes on so we get we can sort of
skip the the rest of it here here are
the important things to take away from
that
I don't even know how to explain this
because it's so insane even though it
was said initially that Jamal Khashoggi
started having trouble when he wrote
articles critical of Saudi Arabia's
action in Yemen I told you on Mondays
show that actually
khashoggi started to be targeted when he
was critical of Donald Trump's position
on Iran right after the 2016 election
why is that the case it's because
Trump's position on Iran is good for
Saudi Arabia this unilateral pulling out
of the Iran deal khashoggi wrote how
that's a bad idea in general and Saudi
Arabia didn't like that and Donald Trump
didn't like that so remember that
officially nothing about Khashoggi has
to do with Iran Trump is asked about
Khashoggi in an interview and he brings
up Iran unprovoked which confirms that
yes it actually has much more to do with
the specific ideas that Khashoggi was
putting out there that Donald Trump
seems indifferent or uncaring about
actually making sure that the people who
killed this guy are held accountable
it's stunning that Donald Trump is
unprovoked mentioning Iran when that's
what we suspect we suspect that actually
Khashoggi got negative attention from
Saudi Arabia and potentially from the
Trump administration is what we're now
speculating because of what he was
saying about Iran and Trump's trade up
brings it up this is truly despotic and
dangerous and if if we don't push this
guy we might never actually get his real
feelings about some of these issues
that's why these written interviews are
so important and that there's one other
part I was going to put up for you that
we won't it's about tariffs Trump again
brought up this idea that the tariffs
increase the tariffs increase revenue
for the United States which is of course
totally absurd the tariffs increase
revenue for the tariffs country and they
increase costs for the
United States of America rambling
egotistical delusional ignorance and
these are the incoherent rants of
someone who's not fit to no insult to
gym managers Trump's not fit to manage a
local gym never mind
the economy of the United States of
America send me your thoughts we are on
Twitter at David Pakman show I'm on
Twitter at Dee Pakman I look forward to
hearing from you let's talk about GM and
American automobiles electric vehicles
subsidies the world economy geopolitics
I don't know where to start other than
to say that Donald Trump is now
threatening to punish American people
who buy electric cars which I suspect
more and more Americans will be doing
every year from here on out why would
Donald Trump do this he has come up with
this as a way to punish General Motors
for restructuring in the direction of
electric cars part of that restructuring
as I told you on Monday or Tuesday is
that General Motors and Ford are both
going to be laying off about 12 to 15
percent of their salaried workforce they
announced that earlier this week now
before I tell you what Trump is
threatening to do remember that Donald
Trump promised to bring manufacturing
jobs back to the United States he said
that auto industry jobs were coming back
all sorts of stuff that's demonstrably
not true that Trump has no idea about
and that simply is not going to happen
so as a baseline Donald Trump isn't
pleased because the real world facts
once again are contradicting the lies of
Donald Trump lies told during the
campaign lies told after he was
inaugurated President of the United
States so what does Trump say he
threatens to cut subsidies on electric
cars which help General Motors sell
electric cars but importantly are
rebates for the buyer okay and we'll get
into that in a second Donald Trump
tweeting about this issue quote very
disappointed with General Motors and
their CEO Mary Barra foreclosing plants
in Ohio Michigan and
nothing being closed in Mexico and China
the u.s. saved General Motors and this
is the thanks we get we are now looking
at cutting all GM subsidies including
for electric cars
General Motors made a big China bet
years ago when they built plants there
and in Mexico don't think that bet is
going to pay off I am here to protect
America's workers to understand how
insane this is consider all of the
following ok
number one the United States is already
hilariously behind on electric vehicles
other than Tesla and it's not even clear
that Donald Trump likes Tesla number two
Donald Trump is one of the biggest
culprits of manufacturing his own
tchotchkes everywhere but the United
States in order to do it as cheaply as
possible so he's a hypocrite on this
issue number three it is true that
subsidies on electric cars helped
General Motors sell more of those cars
but the savings on those cars the
rebates the credits on those vehicles go
to the individuals who are buying the
cars so in reality you're hurting the
individual consumer when you if you
eliminate these subsidies number four
the subsidies aren't specific to general
motors electric car subsidies are
industry-wide okay they are federal tax
credits of seventy five hundred bucks
for American electric cars up to two
hundred thousand vehicles per
manufacturer so if Donald Trump gets rid
of these subsidies they aren't just
subsidies for general motors these are
subsidies for all manufacturers that I
guess he isn't trying to punish
potentially and number five these are
once again targeted threats to
individual companies from the President
of the United States for something that
in the end is partially his fault right
if you want to help manufacturing do
something to improve the business
environment that's the opposite of
putting tariffs on the raw materials
that automakers need so this entire
thing is a problem for
sip it ated by Donald Trump's terrible
economic policy his ideas are as
misguided as they are stupid and as
destructive as they are embarrassing but
there is a contingent of the electorate
Pat that will see this they'll see the
tariffs and they'll see Trump slamming
GM and threatening with the removal of
electric car subsidies and they'll say I
like it he's being tough he's getting
serious on manufacturing which
completely ignores the fact that what
he's doing hurts these companies yeah
and Trump is acting so offended by what
GM has done here maybe because he
thought that by giving them some big tax
break that would mean that GM would keep
the American workers employed no they're
just gonna do whatever maximizes their
profits that's what corporations do and
there really should be no surprise here
no question about it that's the thing
there's some of these stories it's like
they're so obvious in a sense and it's
sort of a weird place to be in because a
lot of our core audience understands
this stuff and the people that don't are
often willingly ignorant they're
deliberately ignoring the empirical
realities of how the world works and how
basic economics works and it's just not
going to matter in the end and that's
why it's ultimately it's all I mean what
what this all comes down to is just
voter turnout right do enough people
vote in 2020 because we're not going to
count on changing the minds of Trump
voters do enough people vote in 2020
that we can get this guy out of office
I'm not convinced that we can even
though there's no shortage of reasons to
do that
check out rejected voicemails on the
David Pakman show
Instagram feed this is a new thing where
a lot of people say you know David you
air one voicemail a day we're curious
about some of the voicemails that don't
make it onto the show a producer max is
now publishing rejected voicemails to
our Instagram account at david pakman
show and while you're there follow me on
instagram as well at david pakman the
next two years are going to be very
uncomfortable for Donald Trump and his
criminal cronies and the investigations
are going to get started
rapidly when Democrats take over the
house in January of 2019 the day after
the midterm
I gave you a list of possible areas of
investigation for Democrats to look at
when they're sworn in and take control
of the house in January and Democrats
now are telling us which are going to be
the top priorities and if you think that
Donald Trump hasn't liked having I don't
know three major investigations into his
administration and family just wait to
see what he's going to do when there are
a dozen or more simultaneous
investigations subpoenas lawsuits and
everything that we're going to see
starting in January of 2019 let's start
from the top
soon-to-be chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee Adam shift Adam
Schiff rather says that an investigation
into Trump's financial ties to Saudi
Arabia are going to be part of an
upcoming investigation this is going to
expose a whole slew of conflicts of
interest and even possibly
constitutional emoluments problems for
Trump and all of this escalated recently
because of Donald Trump siding with
Saudi Arabia over the killing of
journalist Jamal khashoggi that's number
one number two Schiff has made it clear
that now that Devin Nunez is out of the
way in the House Intelligence Committee
and Democrats are going to be back in
control the house is going to
reinvigorate that Trump Russia probe
which the House Intelligence Committee
ended what did they say Pat no evidence
of wrongdoing and just no reason to even
interview all the witnesses and no
problem with Devin Nunez running to
trump to tell him what they were doing
that one's coming back and I'm very much
looking forward to that
well it's certainly worth looking into I
just think that at this point any major
findings in the Trump Russia situation
is going to come from the Muller probe
as opposed to the House or Senate
Intelligence Committee investigations
but I take your point and I certainly
welcome it Democrats in the House
Oversight Committee are going to look
into Ivanka Trump's use of private email
for government business which might
violate federal law but her emails right
that's actually going to be part of a
bigger investigation into private email
use it turns out I mean it's just so
absurd it's been
projection after projection after
projection in this administration after
all the talk about Hillary's emails
there's now going to be a broad
investigation into private email use by
Jared Kushner and Ivanka and former
chief of staff Reince Priebus and it's a
whole long list of Trump staffers that
have been using private email there are
five investigations planned just into
Donald Trump's completely in over her
head Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos
five committees all of which will soon
be controlled by Democrats have elements
of Betsy divorces reign of terror that
they want to look into this includes
Veterans Affairs this includes House
Appropriations it's a long list so this
is just the tip of the iceberg this
could cause Trump to become even more
erratic even more unhinged you can even
imagine that and I'm not going to give
you the full list of possible
investigations again but the important
piece is for everybody saying things
like Dems should play nice so that
things can get done or Democrats should
focus on bipartisanship have you
forgotten the Obama years if you don't
hit them as hard as possible and go
after them for everything that they've
done I'm not saying trumped-up charges
I'm saying go after them for what
they've done or what we suspect they've
done if you don't do that you lose
because they attack either way all the
time okay the idea that now they're
going to play nice if Democrats just
play nice it's ridiculous okay whoever
becomes House Speaker Republicans are
going to attack whatever Democrats try
to do on health care or on daca or on
climate change Republicans are going to
attack they will never hold the other
side to the same standard Hilary will
bomb Syria if you elect her Trump bomb
Syria oh they deserved it
great show of strength by Trump
definitely not a Russian puppet Hillary
Clinton will use cronyism to get out of
all her crimes
Trump literally firing people to
obstruct and invest
into his potential crime oh well the
investigation was a witch-hunt hilary
and humi Abaddon's use of private email
should put them in prison
Oh Kushner and Ivanka and Reince Priebus
they all use private email well listen
those rules are very hard to stick to
and it's all just a witch-hunt
if we're lucky 2019 is going to be a
nightmare for Donald Trump and if his
behavior since the midterms is any
indication it seems that he knows it it
seems that it's going to be a tough
couple of years for him and I'm looking
forward to it I hope you are too Donald
Trump is now proposing a state-run media
network to show the world how great he
is and how great his administration is
one of the hallmarks of authoritarian
autocratic regimes is state-run
propaganda media networks where the
reports about what government are doing
are coming from government funded media
outlets so what I'm talking about here
is how Russia has our tea how the Qatari
government funds al-jazeera how
Venezuela funds this channel called
talas or which you may or may not have
heard of how North Korea has that state
media station I think at KCNA I think
it's called China has it there are many
many examples of this and Trump has been
trying to figure out how to get that
pesky media to stop reporting the truth
about him and his administration and
he's floated I mean let's think back Pat
he had the idea of journalism licenses
very early on in his campaign he wanted
to open up libel laws to make it easier
to sue media outlets
he's threatened to shut down media that
he doesn't like with an executive order
doesn't appear as though that would be
legal I'm forgetting some others I feel
like but remember there is no bigger fan
of free speech and a free press than
Donald Trump and so now in that spirit
of free free free speech and a free
press Donald Trump is
the idea of state-run media he tweeted
about this yesterday saying quote while
CNN doesn't do great in the United
States based on ratings outside of the
u.s. they have very little competition
throughout the world CNN has a powerful
voice portraying the United States in an
unfair and false way something has to be
done including the possibility of the
United States starting our own worldwide
network to show the world the way we
really are great that's right
the president is suggesting a pro Trump
state-run channel to show the rest of
the world how great everything is in the
United States and how great everything
is that is done by the United States
it's effectively a Ministry of
propaganda okay someone wrote to me
saying David we have this already
it's called Fox News to which I said
well yeah we basically do have it
although Fox News sometimes lets the
truth slip out when chef Smith is on the
air or sometimes when Chris Wallace is
on the air one time when Neil Cavuto was
on the air the truth slipped out a trump
state media would not allow that it
would just be all Trump all the time and
interestingly this is just so funny
because Trump clearly has no idea about
this the u.s. actually does sort of have
this already there is a network called
Voice of America which broadcast around
the world and it's basically PR for the
u.s. in foreign countries Trump may be
totally unaware of it
but even voice of America's director
Amanda Bennett said last year she's not
going to be manipulated by Trump so it
may be a sort of pro-us worldwide
network but it's not going to be Trump's
personal propaganda tool so clearly
Trump wants something here that's more
like our tea in Russia or KCNA in North
Korea or Telus or in Venezuela he's
proposing things that normally the right
says we have to be careful with like
what happened Pat to the right saying
it's dangerous when the government
controls the media but now Trump says it
or Trump does it when it comes to other
policies and all of a sudden the right
says either oh he's just kidding around
or it's no longer something we have to
worry about it's not a double standard
because of course it's just okay when
Trump does it but do you remember in the
early days of the Trump administration
larra Trump launched the real news
update it was like two or three minute
long Facebook videos that's apparently
still going on so maybe we can scale
that up that can be the new propaganda
arm that Trump is searching for it's
clearly what he wants and this is what
happens in authoritarian regimes and the
truth is that if anything we have the
opposite problem like yeah you do see
some critical reporting about Trump
but given what Trump is doing there
should be way more of that serious
critical reporting about the disaster
that is the Trump administration and
then I was reminded imagine of a station
that simply broadcasts every Trump
speech without comment worldwide every
press conference that he gives every
executive order signing ceremony but not
with commentary that would do more to
turn the world against Donald Trump than
you can imagine and it's just a sign of
the hyper normalization that we are
experiencing a call by the President of
the United States for state-run media
and it's like on the third or fourth
page of the top news stories of the day
online because of the hyper
normalization that we've experienced
something this nuts
imagine if Obama did this imagine if
Bush did this it barely gets attention
when it's happening in the Trump era
follow the David Pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
at david pakman a lot of
behind-the-scenes pictures comments
highlighted comments from the audience
and much more quick break
Andrew Torres will join me next to talk
about court packing what is it can
Democrats do it should Democrats do it
we often talk about the top meta issues
in the world of politics in our economy
in our culture and I often name campaign
finance I talk about Internet freedom
and we talk about economic justice and
inequality and I mention climate change
because if you're cities under water
that's really bad
for the economy if people are dying from
heat that's really bad for the economy
we've talked about that before and of
course the current President believes
that climate change isn't real
or if it's real it's not caused by
humans or it's a hoax created by the
Chinese we've heard basically every
version of climate denial from the
current President of the United States
and I've been making the point that
aside from just being a moral issue and
an environmental issue and a health
issue for humans climate change is a
national security issue and it's also an
economic issue and Donald Trump's own
administration now released a climate
change report hilariously enough they
buried it by releasing it the day after
Thanksgiving which says climate change
is real it's caused by humans and it is
a massive emergency crisis level problem
what does trump say about his own
administration's climate change report
says he doesn't believe it says he
doesn't believe this dire report about
the state of climate change from his own
administration take a look at what he
had to say when he was asked about it
the other day
I've seen it I've read some of it and
it's fine
yeah I don't believe it no no I don't
believe it and here's the other thing
you're gonna have to have China and
Japan and all of Asia and all of these
other countries you know address
addresses our country right now we're at
the cleanest we've ever been and that's
very important gentlemen but if we're
clean but every other place on earth is
dirty that's not so good so I want clean
air I want clean water very important
yeah so he's actually right that this is
not an issue that lends itself to
nationalist solutions Trump correctly
identifies if we are clean and they're
not or they're not and they are and
we're not whatever you need Global
Solutions to this issue and that's
actually what I've been saying for years
and it's one of the reasons why right
now in particular nationalist ideologies
are not going to serve us well but Trump
is asked what about the economic impact
and he says yeah well I don't believe it
this is a report from 13 federal
agencies within the Trump administration
its peer reviewed the report looks at
the economic impact as quote hundreds of
billions of dollars in annual losses to
many economic sectors if we don't act
now the report makes clear it's not just
something to deal with in the future
this is a problem now climate change is
causing more wildfires it's causing poor
air quality emissions have to be cut so
Trump believes authoritarian dictators
over our own intelligence when it comes
to Russian meddling he believes brutal
the theocratic dictators over our
intelligence agencies when it comes to
the killing of Jamal khashoggi and I
guess Pat he believes I don't even know
who over his own federal agencies on the
issue of climate change I guess it's the
climate skeptics as they call themselves
we call them deniers so none of this is
new Pat a Trump doesn't believe in
climate change but the really disturbing
thing to me is that number one even when
his own administration
fine intelligence agencies he believes
are politically biased his own
administration's agencies are telling
him this and he still doesn't believe it
and you know what that says to me Pat
that means to me that if you say to
Trump well what evidence if we had it
would change your mind that the answer
is none because he's not dealing in fact
yeah and like you identified and Trump
identified this is the problem that has
to have some sort of global solution
well we had at least the blueprint for
that that was the Paris climate Accord
and of course Trump decided to pull out
from that so I don't know what his
alternative solution is going to be and
you're also right about how he tends to
side with foreign governments over our
own intelligence community over his own
administration well I think he's on his
own island on this one because even the
most adversarial countries around the
world to the US agree that climate
change is happening and it's a problem
that we have to solve yeah it's not even
like on this one we say Trump's position
on climate change is that of these six
authoritarian dictators from around the
world which by the way seems to be his
position on issues related to press
freedom and so many other things even
those countries recognize the reality of
climate change this is an existential
threat this climate change is an
existential threat to humanity and Trump
as someone in a position of power in
determining policy on this issue is
dangerous and the worst part about it is
that his voters aren't going to hold
them accountable which is why we need to
by voting and I don't know if we're
going to do it I really hope that we are
send me your thoughts what do you make
of Trump not believing his own
administration's climate change report
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show I'm on Twitter at Dee Pakman and
boy do we have a good program for you
today